what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we are talking about the future of
the marvel cinematic universe as marvel
studios has released four new release
dates in 2024 for upcoming movies and
based off of what we believe these
movies to be the next couple of years
are truly going to be insane from
spider-man no way home to doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness to movies
like deadpool 3 and the fifth avengers
film coming out things are about to get
crazy and not to mention we are getting
at least four movies a year from marvel
studios four movies not including any of
the disney plus projects that they put
out as well that's four movies a year
plus three or four disney plus projects
and the really cool thing is that
eventually all of these different disney
plus projects and movies are all going
to come together so let's talk about
what these upcoming movies are and what
the future holds for us and if you're
new and you want to stay up to date on
the mcu be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so like i
mentioned marvel released four new spots
for movies coming in 2024. four movies
in 2024 with the release dates of
february 16th may 3rd july 26th and
november 8th so this is incredible news
but actually as it stands right now we
actually have five movies coming in
2023. here is marvel's release date
schedule and movies as it stands right
now of course this year in 2021 on
november 5th we have the eternals then
of course we have spiderman no way home
on december 17th going into 2022 on
march 25th we have multiverse of madness
then on may 6th we have thor love and
thunder july 8th we have black panther 2
wakanda forever then november 11th the
last one of 2022 we have the marvels
then rolling into 2023
february 17th we have ant-man and the
wasp quantum mania and then on may 5th
we have a guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
so those are the two movies we already
know about in 2023 but then we have
three more july 28th october 6th and
november 10th so as of right now we
actually have seven untitled mcu
projects that have release dates so of
course the big question is what are
these projects and that's what we're
here to talk about today as it turns out
we actually have a pretty good idea of
what they're going to be now the first
one i want to start off talking about is
my man deadpool ryan reynolds has
actually been pretty open about deadpool
and the plans over at marvel studios for
deadpool 3. deadpool 3 is currently in
the works right now ryan reynolds and
the other writers are working on the
script every day literally from what
i've heard from people who actually talk
to him they say literally he just works
on that script all day every day which
is fantastic because now he's in the mcu
you know it's gonna hit harder and kevin
feige actually did confirm in an
interview with brandon davis of
comicbook.com that they do have a
release date in mind for deadpool 3
already so it is safe to assume that one
of these 2024 release dates or possibly
even a 2023 release date is for deadpool
3. ryan reynolds believes that they are
going to be done filming next year so in
2023 or 2024 i'm definitely saying we're
going to be getting deadpool 3. another
project that'll most likely be in 2024
is something i'm super excited about and
i know everybody else has as well the
fantastic four now kevin feige
originally announced the fantastic four
at 2019 san diego comic con i didn't
even have time to talk about the
fantastic four
and a couple of years have gone by since
then however since then within a year of
from where we are right now kevin feige
has talked about the process of the
fantastic four being developed and
during disney's investor day kevin feige
announced as one of the upcoming
projects the fantastic four being one of
them the fantastic four is actively
being developed right now and since that
is the case it's actively being
developed and worked on i'm going to say
it is going to be a part of that 2024
release slate now another movie that we
believe is going to be coming in one of
these slots either in 2023 or 2024 is a
new captain america movie starring
anthony mackie according to the report
from deadline they actually have malcolm
spellman who wrote the falcon and the
winter soldier returning to right
captain america 4. and since he's fresh
off of riding the falcon and the winter
soldier he's probably jumping into
captain america 4 already not to mention
the new avengers which i'll get to in a
bit are probably going to be coming
within the next few years and since
captain america basically led the old
avengers maybe sam is going to be the
captain america to lead the new avengers
but he definitely is going to need his
own movie before that happens yes he got
the falcon and the winter soldier but
he's going to need his own movie focused
on him and since it has the same writer
of the falcon and the winter soldier we
can assume that it is going to dive deep
into sam's backstory there's still a lot
we actually don't really know about sam
we haven't heard much about his time in
the air force and not to mention we
don't really know much about the time
where him steve rogers and natasha
romanoff were on the run those events
between captain america civil war and
avengers infinity war are pretty unknown
to us with the exception of what we
learned in black widow now another movie
coming in one of these slots which is
going to take us to a different part of
the mcu is blade mahershala ali is blade
and i gotta say that's pretty perfect
casting and this is going to take us to
the more monstrous side of the mcu
opening it up to a completely new and
different direction an area that we
haven't been in yet this along with moon
knight i think is going to take us in
more of a darker direction i think one
division kind of took that first step
with introducing witches and agatha
harkness and now i hope that blade moon
knight and hopefully a midnight suns
project is going to leap into our mcu
monsterverse now phase four even though
it was supposed to start a lot earlier
than it did started this year in 2021
won division kicked us off on disney
plus and black widow kicked us off with
movies and that means by the end of 2024
we'll have gone three three and a half
years and that means it's pretty much
time for a team-up crossover film
perhaps the next avengers movie
obviously a new team of avengers has to
assemble in the mcu now since the old
ones well a lot of them are gone and
like i said the new captain america
movie could be so that they could start
to set up the new avengers team but also
not to mention we do believe that two
other avengers teams are going to be
coming the young avengers and the dark
avengers the falcon and the winter
soldier and black widow made it pretty
clear that a new team was being
assembled by valentina and it's only a
matter of time until we see this team on
screen this could be the dark avengers
or it could be the thunderbolts team we
have characters like john walker elena
belova zemo and probably a lot more in
the background right now ready to be a
part of some big team the only question
is right now when are we going to see
them and what team is it well since
they've actively been showing us the
team being assembled i wouldn't be
surprised if one of these slots in 2024
is reserved for whatever team this is
going to be the thunderbolts or dark
avengers and two of these slots could
very well be for both teams the normal
avengers and then a young avengers or
dark avengers team but of course this
list would not be complete if we weren't
talking about mutants slash the x-men
now i firmly believe we are going to
have individual mutants introduced to
the mcu before we get a big x-men film i
hope they do it like the original
avengers were assembled individual
movies then they come together to form
the x-men kind of like first class but
hopefully a lot better hopefully more
like the avengers devote one movie to
one or a couple of mutants have another
one of those movies then another one and
then have an x-men assemble movie now
kevin feige did also announce the mutant
x-men at 2019 san diego comic-con as
well
[Applause]
[Applause]
so we know that the movie is being
thought about and probably being
developed right now not to mention we
have had some reports from some outlets
stating that a mutant's movie is in
development although that can't be
officially confirmed at this time but
kevin feige announced them two years ago
and the ending of 2004 is three years
away that means since the announcement
of the mutants coming to the mcu to the
ending of 2024 that is five years that's
plenty of time to develop a mutant movie
so that movie could very well be a part
of that 2024 slate that has just been
announced by marvel studios these movies
are what i think we have the best
chances of seeing in 2023 and 2024 based
of what marvel studios has already
announced but let me know what you think
about this list in the comments down
below and let me know what you would
like to see movie wise fill some of
these slots in 2023 and 2024 don't
forget to subscribe for more videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof